so maybe let's talk about that a little
bit the world of asics and
yeah well actually you're uh
you're you have a new role at sci-fi
what's that place about what is the
vision sure
uh so for their vision for i would say
the future of computer yeah so i lead
the engineering product teams at
sci-five
sci-five is a company who's
was founded with this architecture
called risk five
risk five is a new instruction set
instruction sets are the things inside
of your computer they tell how to run
things
um x86 from intel and arm from
the arm company and things like this or
other instruction sets i've talked to
signature up i talked to dave patterson
who's super excited about risk five
dave dave is awesome yeah he's brilliant
yeah the uh
risk five is distinguished by not being
proprietary
and so xa6 can only be made by intel and
amd
arm can only be made by arm they sell
licenses to build arm ships to other
companies things like this
mips is another instruction set that is
owned by the mips company now wave
and then it gets licensed out things
like that and so risk five is an open
standard
that anybody can build chips for and so
sci-fi was founded by
three of the founders of risk five that
designed and built it in berkeley
working with dave and so that was the
the genesis of the company
sci-fi today has some of the world's
best five cores and we're
selling them and that's really great
they're going to tons of products it's
very exciting
so they're taking this uh thing that's
open source and just being
trying to be or are the best in the
world at building these things yeah so
here it's the specifications open source
it's like saying
tcp is an open standard or c is an open
standard
but then you have to build an
implementation of the standard and so
cy5
on the one hand pushes forward and
defined and pushes forward the standard
on the other hand we have
implementations
that are best in class for different
points in the space depending on if you
want a
really tiny cpu or if you want a really
big beefy one that
that is faster but it uses more area and
things like this what about the actual
manufacturer
chip so like what yeah so where does
that all fit i'm gonna ask a bunch of
dumb questions that's okay
this is how we learn right and so
uh what the way this works is that
there's
generally a separation of the people who
design the circuits and then people who
manufacture them
and so that you'll hear about fabs like
tsmc and samsung and things like this
that actually produce the chips but they
take a design coming in
and that design specifies how um how the
you know you turn uh code
for the chip into uh little rectangles
that then
use photo lithography to make uh mask
sets and then burn transistors onto a
chip or onto a onto silicon rather
so and we're talking about mass
manufacturing so
yeah they're talking about making
hundreds of millions of parts and things
like that yeah and so the fab handles
the volume production things like that
but um when you look at this problem um
the interesting thing about the space
when you look at it is that
um these the steps that you go from
designing a chip and writing the
quote-unquote code for it
and things like verilog and languages
like that
down to what you hand off to the fab is
a really
well studied really old problem okay
um tons of people have worked on it lots
of smart people have built systems and
tools
these tools then have generally gone
through acquisitions and so they've
ended up at three different major
companies that build and sell these
tools
they're called eda tools like for
electronic design automation
the problem with this is you have huge
amounts of fragmentation
you have loose standards
and the tools don't really work together
so you have tons of duct tape and you
have tons of uh
lost productivity now these are these
are tools for designing
so the risk five is a instruction
like what is risk five like how deep
does it go
how how much does it touch the hardware
how much does it define
how much of the hardware is yeah so risk
five is all about
um given a cpu so the the the processor
and your computer
how does the the compiler like the swift
compiler the c compiler things like this
how does it make it work so it's what is
the assembly code
and so you write risk 5 assembly instead
of x86 assembly for example
but it's a set of instructions as
opposed to instructions
what do you say it tells you how the
compiler works well
sorry it's what the compiler talks to
okay yeah and then uh
so the tooling you mentioned that the
disparate tools are for what
for when you're building a specific chip
so wrist five in hardware
in hardware yeah so so risk five you can
buy a risk five core from sci-fi
and say hey i wanna have a certain
number of run a certain number of
gigahertz i want it to be this big
i want to be have these features i won't
have
like i want floating point or not for
example
and then what you get is you get a
description of a cpu with those
characteristics
now if you want to make a chip you want
to build like an iphone chip or
something like that
right you have to take both the cpu but
then you have to talk to memory
you have to have timers ios a gpu
other components and so you need to pull
all those things together
into what's called an asic an
application specific integrated circuit
so a custom chip
and then you take that design and then
you have to transform it into something
that the fabs
like tsmc for example know how to
turn take to production got it so but
yeah okay and and so that process
i will i can't help but see it is
is a big compiler okay yeah
it's a whole bunch of compilers written
without thinking about it
through that lens isn't the universe a
compiler
like compilers do two things they
represent things and transform them yeah
and so there's a lot of things that end
up being compilers yeah but this is this
is a space where
we're talking about design and usability
and the way you think about things the
way
things compose correctly it matters a
lot and so
sci-fi is investing a lot into that
space and we think there's a lot a lot
of benefit that can be made by allowing
people to design chips faster
get them to market quicker and scale out
because
um you know at the alleged more end of
moore's law
you've got this problem of uh you're not
getting free
performance just by waiting another year
for a faster cpu
and so you have to find performance in
other ways and one of the ways to do
that is with custom accelerators and
other things in hardware and and so
what we'll talk a little bit about uh
a little more about asics but uh do you
see
that a lot of people a lot of companies
will try to
have like different sets of requirements
that this whole process to go for so
like
like almost different car companies
might use different uh
and like different uh pc manufacturers
like so is this
like is risk five um in this whole
process
is it potentially the future of all
computing devices
yeah i think that so if you look at risk
five and step back from the silicon side
of things
risk five is an open standard and one of
the things
that has happened over the course of
decades if you look over the long arc of
computing
somehow became decades old yeah okay so
you have
companies that come and go and you have
instruction sets that come and go
like one example of this out of many is
uh
uh sun was spark yeah some went away
spark still lives on at fujitsu but we
have
hp had this instruction set called pa
risk
so pa risk was its big server business
and had tons of customers
they decided to move to this
architecture called itanium
from intel yeah this didn't work out so
well
yeah right and so you have this issue of
you're making many billion dollar
investments on instruction sets that are
owned by a company
and even companies as big as intel don't
always execute as well as they could
they have their own issues um hp for
example decided that it wasn't in their
best interest to continue investing in
the space because it was very expensive
and so they make
technology decisions or prod they make
their own business decisions and this
means that as a customer
what do you do you've sunk all this time
all this engineering all the software
work all these
you've built other products around them
and now you're stuck
right what risk 5 does is it provides
you more optionality in the space
because if you buy an implementation of
risk 5 from sci five
and you should they're the best ones
yeah um
uh but if something bad happens to sci
five in 20 years
right well great you can turn around and
buy rs5 core from somebody else
and there's an ecosystem of people that
are all making different risk five cores
with
different trade-offs which means that if
you have more than one requirement if
you have a family of products you can
probably find
something in the wrist five space that
fits your needs whereas
with if you're talking about xa6 for
example
it's intel's only going to bother to
make certain classes of devices
right i see so uh maybe a weird question
but
like if sci-fi is
uh like infinitely successful in the
next 20 30 years what does the world
look like
so like how does the world of computing
change
so too much diversity and hardware
instruction sets i think is bad
like we have a lot of people that are
using um
lots of different instruction sets
particularly in the embedded the like
very tiny microcontroller space the
thing in your toaster
um that uh that are just
weird and different for historical
reasons and so the compilers and the
tool chains and the languages on top of
them
aren't there and so the developers for
that software have to use really weird
tools
because the ecosystem that supports is
not big enough
so i expect that will change right
people will have better tools and better
languages better features everywhere
that then can service many different
points in the space um
and i think risk five will progressively
um
eat more of the ecosystem because it can
scale up it can scale down sideways
left right it's very flexible and very
well considered well-designed
instruction set i think when you look at
sci-fi of tackling silicon
and how people build chips which is a
very different
space um that's where you say i think
we'll see a lot more custom chips
and that means that you get much more
battery life you get better
better tuned solutions for your
iot thingy so you get you get
people that move faster you get the
ability to have faster time to market
for example
so how many custom so first of all on
the iot side of things do you see
the number of smart toasters
increasing exponentially so
and if you do like how much
customization per toaster is there
do all those in the world run the same
uh
silicon like the same design or is it
different companies have different
design like how much
how much customization is possible here
well a lot of it comes down to cost
right right and so the way that chips
work is you end up paying by the
one one of the factors is the the size
of the chip
and so what ends up happening just from
an economic perspective is
there's only so many chips that get made
in a year of a given design
and so often what customers end up
having to do is they end up having to
pick up a chip that exists that was
built for somebody else so that they can
then ship their product
and the reason for that is they don't
have the volume of the iphone they can't
afford to build a custom chip
however what that means is they're now
buying an off-the-shelf chip
that isn't really good isn't a perfect
fit for their needs and so they're
paying a lot of money for it
because they're buying silicon that
they're not using
well if you now reduce the cost of
designing the chip
now you get a lot more chips and the
more you reduce it
the the easier it is to design chips the
more
the world keeps evolving and we get more
ai accelerators we get more other things
we get more
uh standards to talk to we get 6g right
you get
you get you get changes in the world
that you want to be able to talk to
these different things there's more
diversity in the cross product of
features that people want
and that drives differentiated chips in
different
in another direction and so nobody
really knows what the future looks like
but um but i think that there's a lot of
silicon in the future
you